are you surprised to hear that federal
government says drink prices about 50
plus percent am I surprised yes I'm very
surprised hear that
why because of drink prices were up 50
percent I'd be doing a heck of a lot
better here in old Fords than that in
doing right now
so this national fifty percent 60
percent number that's not in your pocket
that is 100 percent not in my pocket
though so how often did drink prices go
up around here around here I'm in
business for about 20 years here in this
location and drink prices go up around a
quarter every four to five years a
quarter a quarter and you hear about it
we certainly hear about it what do
people say oh I can't believe you raised
the prices again again we our last price
increase was over four years ago so
places like New York Chicago Dallas the
prices are going up no doubt why do you
think that is
I believe it's almost it's almost to the
point of price gouging bigger cities
obviously you have your options to do
that people in the inner cities have the
option to go to if you're just we
discussed just a vegan type of place if
you're a craft pulse people like to go
to a craft bar wait hold on back up even
price gouging well I think in the bigger
cities is price gouging and I'm a guy
purchasing the same bottle of liquor
well use a bottle of Grey Goose as an
example the bottles of liquor we see
over there same price you're paying
they're paying down in New York
absolutely same prices we're paying the
same price I'm buying the same $30
bottle of Grey Goose at a bar in New
Jersey or a bar in Manhattan is buying
yet I could get $8 for a martini the bar
in New Jersey you get 1295 and the bar
in Manhattan can get 18 bucks so I'm in
small town USA they're in metropolitan
USA how much this is an $8 drink right
here that's a $5 raise it's a $5 $5
drink we're only two hours from New York
and you're right so you're telling me
that the the wholesale beer and liquor
cost in Scranton or Old Forge is the
same as what they're paying in the big
cities it's exactly the same and yet the
big city cost is four or five six times
more five six times more yeah sometimes
more than that
depends on the trendy bar the trendy
restaurant because they know there only
to be trendy for two years so it's a
it's a hit and run make my money and get
out so if I'm if I'm a bar patron I'm a
drinker
wait and I get my bill at the end the
night and I'm angry mm-hmm who should I
be angry at certainly not at the owner
not here not here if I'm sitting in New
York City right now or Nashville or
definitely with me no you're not no and
you're not happy with your local bar
either well I think a lot of the patrons
are happier or happier with their local
bar because if you're a guy that goes
out after work two or three nights a
week and you wanna have a sandwich you
wanna have a couple beers you're
generally going through the smaller
corner hometown bar you're not going
through the trendy place because the
trendy place is going to be trendy for
two years 36 months tops they're in
they're out so you hear that the the the
profit margin at a successful restaurant
nationally these days is like two to
four percent if you're doing five or six
percent you're doing well yeah is that
true for here that's true that's very
true so it's not a big margin business
it is definitely not a big margin
business and it's especially not as big
of margin business as it was 10 15 and
well 20 years ago we've been hearing
about bars going out of business why
competition number one price-wise number
two trying to keep up and trying to
price yourself not out of the market but
trying to keep your prices reasonable
with your competition but that's the
problem some of these big cities is the
the the cocktail is $12 or $15
everywhere yeah you can't find a $5
drink if you go outside the city you
will inside the cities you're right you
won't you won't because they have it
locked down the prices are locked into
what they are and they're not changing
why would somebody
why would somebody that you get $12 for
a drink all of a sudden say you know
what I think I'm gonna be the
trendsetter and only charge seven for
mine never do it right what I mean this
all started 15 years ago according to
the data the price we're shooting I
would agree
don't worry with that data yeah okay
what was it about that moment well I
think that's where the cash and credit
chose also to the currency
20 years ago when I opened up Dooley's
here with my partner we would see on a
weekly basis an 80 percent cash business
20 percent debit and credit fast-forward
20 years later we're now a 20 percent
cash business 80 percent debit and
credit cards and so you've got to pay a
fee pay a fee on every one of those
cards every one of those transactions
we've also heard from some bar owners in
New York that in the old days when you
were all cash you didn't necessarily
have to tell the IRS I don't know
anything about that
always paid my taxes hypothetically
speaking though in an industry that is
all cash hypothetically speaking in an
entry that was all cash you didn't
necessarily have to tell true the IRS
everything not everything this is true
but now you do because most of us coming
on the card know 80 to 90 percent is
coming on the card so there's no way
around it I kind of I gotta think that
ends up in the price too absolutely
that's why the prices are gradually
going up slowly but surely